it is time once again to check in with
our friend mercedes martinez from las
vegas now and mix941 mercedes
i am desperate to know what is trending
this morning besides of course you
oh well i've got you covered aside from
you also but the dating app
bumble is banning body shaming
it made the announcement this week
saying find something else about their
pro
talk about or if you're not interested
in someone you can swipe left
bumble uses automated safeguard to
d they detect comments and images that
it prohibits but they also really depend
on users to report people repeat
offenders
they will be banned completely
now on to katy perry and orlando bloom
the couple
is waiting a little while longer to tie
the knot
according to entertainment tonight
they've decided to put their wedding
burner for now because they want to
focus on being parents
instead the couple they had their first
baby together in august little daisy
dove
and i think they're going to kind of
just concentrate on that for now
john nothing wrong with that especially
during the pandemic if you want to have
a big
big wedding you have to wait before you
can have everybody get together so you
know press pause a little bit focus on
the kid and
wait until everything's opened back up
again mercedes one thing that we like
here on
good day las vegas is spicy food looks
like someone else is trying to help us
out to
fulfill that need we have oh yes
absolutely mickey d's is bringing back a
fan favorite the spicy
chicken nuggets and the mighty hot sauce
you can now order them starting on
monday but some people online say
they're already back at some mcdonald's
so it might be worth a
a little trip to the drive-through if if
spice is what you like spice up your
life a little bit john
just yeah hopefully i need more of the
mcnuggets to do that but
if people wait in line and they ask to
get the spice mcnuggets and they're not
there
just keep doing the circle around until
they finally say they've got it just you
know do that
lying around you'll be they'll take care
of you eventually
definitely happening on monday for sure
but you know maybe there's a secret
handshake or a knock on the door that
you can do to get them
[Music]
the secret word is mercedes martinez
oh don't don't use me no
okay fair enough well have a good
weekend mercedes enjoy the rest of the
program and again you can listen to
mercedes on mix 941 and las vegas now
coming up later today
good to see you mercedes take care
yourself